Typically, what you're going to see in a supplement, if you go to the store,
buy a vitamin E supplement, I'll say alpha to cough or all, or mixed to cough orals, or alpha,
beta, gamma, delta, to cough or all. But it's the to cough orals that are not the ones you want
to use. If you have heart conditions, it's not the ones that you want to use for cancer.
It's the inner portion of the vitamin E. Those are the total triadols, kind of confusing.
The total triadols are the inner portions and the to cough orals are the outer portions. It's very
easy to synthesize those outer portions, the to cough orals in the laboratory. That's why you're
going to see them in store bought vitamins usually. The toco triadols, the inner portion, it's typically,
that's not typically, it's specifically the gamma and delta toco triadols, that are the important
components of the vitamin E that is good for cancer and good for the heart. There's several studies
of the gamma and delta toco triadols for cancer and for the heart, and you can certainly just
google scholar those studies as well. They're very impressive.